now if you think you're too old to deal
with modern technology maybe lily ebbert
can teach you a thing or two age 97
lily's become a star on the tick tock
video sharing platform she's gained more
than a million followers for her clips
in which she answers people's questions
about surviving the holocaust when she
was a prisoner at the notorious nazi
death camp auschwitz
were you afraid of death in auschwitz
[Music]
in auschwitz you were not afraid of that
you were afraid to live
when lily ebert talks that was very
shocking
the world listens
at 97 lily is one of the last remaining
survivors of the nazi death camp
auschwitz
with the help of her 17 year old great
grandson dov she now shares her
experiences on tiktok to an audience of
millions
before
what tick-tock is
if somebody would come and tell me
tick-tock
i heard this word but they don't know
what you are talking about
[Music]
she does now
in the space of a few months they've
picked up 1.2 million followers offering
them a precious chance to ask her
questions directly
do you still believe in god yes i do
because not god daily
it's just incredibly incredible to see
how many people actually want to learn
and care and want to ask questions and
at times it's very sad to learn about
what happened to her and her family but
again it's got such importance the story
is of monumental importance we're really
in the last moments of hearing the
holocaust survivors first hand
lillian dove came up with the idea
during a covert lockdown earlier this
year when lily became unable to share
her stories in person
after surviving kovit herself the
importance of documenting her accounts
became even clearer
when the survivors are gone are gone
nobody we can ask nobody it is nobody
here anymore really to us what really
happened
but now suddenly i see
no is the last movement
my number is
a
10
572.
[Music]
this video alone hit over 20 million
views and counting
is a platform beyond anything they
imagined
i think it's so important the work that
we are doing giving people messages of
hope tolerance survival the importance
of never giving up and so i think we
feel incredibly proud proud but also
excited to have the platform
lily and dove are an unstoppable team
having mastered social media they've now
written a book reaching an even broader
audience
and fulfilling lily's life's work
ensuring the tragedies of the holocaust
are never forgotten
i promised
myself
if
i by any chance will survive
i will tell the world that will be my
aim
that the world should know
what can happen
well you saw lily ebert's great grandson
doll foreman in that report he joins us
now welcome dov so tell us more about
your your great grandmother and how she
got into social media
well as you heard in the report before
my great-grandmother is 97 and growing
up with my
as a holocaust survivor she often told
me about her experiences in auschwitz
but it was always at a very surface
level and never really what actually
happened to her because i don't think
she wanted to hurt us but i also think
she didn't want to hurt herself but as
it said in the reports during the first
knockdown my great-grandmother and i
were separated for the first time and
for the first time in her life she
wasn't able to go to schools and
universities and different workplaces to
educate about her holocaust testimony so
i felt a really
a need to go on social media and
introduce her to the new online world
and even though often our generation is
taught to be wary of the dangers of
social media i thought right i need to
get her on tiktok and twitter and share
her story with the world in it
and what is the the story about an
american soldier and a banknote
so
when i was first speaking to her about
wanting to learn more about her story
she wanted to take me to her flat and
show me all the things that she has from
that time and she actually showed me she
wanted sorry
she wanted to show me a football shirt
that was signed by a football team where
she went to talk and share her testimony
and when she was showing me this
football shirt i noticed in the back of
her cupboard a pile of photos
from the time of after the holocaust and
up till now and amongst these photos
were was a banknote that was given to
her by an american liberator when she
was liberated from the banknote from the
death march and on this banknote she was
written 10 words of hope the start to a
new life good luck and happiness and
when i saw this i straightaway wanted to
share this message of kindness on
twitter and i posted it on twitter and
it went viral within eight hours it was
seen by two million people and it turned
into an international hunt for this
soldier and we managed to find him and
have a zoo meeting with his family oh
how fantastic but there has been some
backlash of abuse i understand what what
happened
yes so
unfortunately with all these positive
messages and 1.2 million followers on
tick tock obviously comes hate messages
from various different people
and i think what i've learned from lilly
is to be strong and to
to just ignore these people and carry on
because what these people are showing it
only emphasizes the needs to do what we
do these people when they send hate it
shows others that
the way to combat hate is through
education and so when we got a lot of a
big wave of anti-semitism and hate
messages my great-grandmother straight
away said to me right we're going to go
on post another video and carry on and
show them that we will not let them win
because we will show everyone what hate
can do and
my great grandmother is a living witness
of the holocaust and she tells me the
whole time the holocaust did not start
with the gas chambers it started with
words and basic hatreds and
anti-semitism and so we must be vigilant
and we must carry on and stand up
against this hatred
we wish you well thanks for sharing that
story with us at dove foreman thank you
thank you